i actually have a very strong uh strong
belief in what i would have told myself
which is let go of the life you have
planned
to accept and embrace the life that is
actually waiting for you
[Music]
amy bianca cohen dagon thank you so much
for joining me how are you
good ma phil nice to be here and thank
you for having me
so you know i usually ask how how would
you like me to introduce you because i i
butcher names all the time i'm i'm the
worst of that if i was an elementary
school teacher
all the kids would be crying but when i
you know so you said amy co in the gun
and then you mentioned that i could
throw in the bianca
in there which is a part of your real
name and now we get abcd
exactly i wonder if you've never met
anyone with such cool initials
not at all that just made my that just
made my day
amy talk to me a little bit about your
journey starting from lawyer
all the way to being acquired by the
biggest beer company now i know
i hear a lot of people getting acquired
by intel google
apple different tech companies i haven't
yet heard being acquired by the biggest
beer company in the world
but i want to go back to being a lawyer
and how do you find yourself
in the beer industry i mean out of
anything
okay so so it's definitely not a not a
very uh clear pot
basically uh since age about seven i
found one of my grade one books
and it said when i grow up i want to be
a lawyer and that was something that i
always
always kind of had envisioned for myself
i used to watch ally mcfeel for the the
for the viewers of us that remember
those programs
um i went i made a liar i moved from
johannesburg from south africa you can
still hear the accents
in israel so basically i studied law
dealt with the law degree in hebrews
suffered through that
very fortunately uh you know finished
with honors and all of that stuff and
then
i went on to to do my my internship at
ugallan which is very big firm in israel
dealing with mnas kind of in the startup
industry and that was kind of the first
exposure to that
now at that point your only interaction
with beer is that you might enjoy
drinking it
maybe and to be fair at the time i was
actually mostly drinking wine so
so very very little interaction with
fear
and at the time i kind of just already
started getting the sense of
you know not really being everything
that i thought it was or in terms of the
types of
you know professional interactions that
i wanted which was more like human
interaction kind of less with documents
and things like that
so kind of i completed that that process
i went to
completed the bar exam and all of that
and then at the time i was doing a
second degree as well which was also in
law that was kind of just business law
so i was like okay let's do that for fun
there are people who study for fun
um and then i was actually at a
conference and i
saw this random little startup at the
time it was a i think
eight people start off called weisberger
which is a
big data for the beer industry uh
startup
um and basically i literally approached
approached this kind of little stand and
i said hey this is very cool what you're
doing they had this like kind of
beer poor manual beer pour and they had
this like screen up with showing data
and i was like okay this is interesting
um and i knew that i at the time kind of
wanted to get into into the tech
industry
and literally the following day sent an
email still have that email
and i was like hey guys this is me i'm
coming to work for you
um it then ended up with me sitting on a
box because at the time in their offices
they were in a street kind of opposite
the beach in tel aviv
and they didn't have a meeting room so
we sat in an actual
room uh with floor meters kind of on the
wall
and i sat on a boat well actually the
co-founder gave me his chair and he sat
on the bus
and that was that was kind of history
that's where it started
i spent four years wow company leading
business development initiatives
marketing strategic projects
not lawyer stuff not lawyer stuff not
lawyer stuff
no any any kind of document that they
gave me i was like hi guys
i'm don't pay for my buyer exam fees i'm
not doing it
wow that's kind of how it started and
yeah
i actually i actually got to visit the
weisberger offices
and before kovid i visited mike margolis
right
who's there because i was i came and i
was
i was meeting a bunch of different
startups and i sat down in the corona
couch
which is now very fitting so i think
that we have a problem there
but you have a whole section with the
corona and the nice fridge and
like sort of the beach right exactly
exactly well those aren't the offices
that i joined
right right right no those were already
already farther along
and talk give me a few sentences beer
technology
intersection when you're talking to me
about business development and marketing
in a company that has something anything
to do with alcohol and beer
i i don't understand that so so you know
for the sake of my me and my friends
explain a little bit what this
intersection could be sure so so
like in any industry essentially in in
the
automotive industry or in any other
industry that we look at right we can
always analyze
uh data and usage um and and in this
case
we're talking about consumers right so
you and i drink beer i've got a
beautiful
budweiser special edition of it yes so
we drink beer and we can analyze at 9 30
a.m
israel viewers 9 30 a.m israel i wasn't
gonna give that up i drink beer in the
morning
it's uh you know i guess it's part of
the part of the job description
i love it i love it i'm going to send
the resume right after this
um so essentially basically uh just for
example
in the context of what weisberger does
is that they're basically taking
millions and billions of data points um
of consumers
habits of the way that we consume beer
when we consistently how we consume beer
um you know in the on-premise sites uh
on-premise meaning bars and restaurants
kind of websites
and they're basically collecting those
insights and essentially giving them
um you know presenting them in different
types of products either to
the bar owners or in this case uh to the
brewery which which is ibm bev
as we were acquired um and that's kind
of the intersection i mean i think
there's a lot of ways to kind of
understand how we consume things
i think that's you know i thought that
was so remarkable and so innovative this
idea that you you attach yourself to two
key points in the in the system and
correct me if i'm wrong but one of these
points is inside the barrel you
understand the quality of the beer
and when you're about to run out one of
the biggest problems of of of bars is
that they don't know what's happening
inside of the barrel
but on the other end it's actually on
the cash register right understanding
what do consumers purchase how do you
optimize for your sales and which type
of beers do you sell you know i'm
thinking as i go to some beers locally
well i haven't been in a bar in about
four months now but
you know in the bars sometimes you have
like 20 different
types of beer there's no way that the
bartender can or the bar owner can keep
track of what's happening
exactly so it's both visibility and
really like you said to optimize kind of
how we sell and and to make sure that we
have the right brand incredible now amy
you were one one of the things that i
that i saw that was very special is you
were actually
very involved with the due diligence
process of of this huge acquisition
uh so what is that like going through
internally within the company going
through due diligence for a potential
acquisition is it stressful
is it just you know ongoing talk to me
so i think that uh just just to kind of
give an exception to what i said that i
wouldn't be dealing with with legal
stuff this is a big exception only
only a huge m a b
so at the time it was actually a very
unique experience for me i was eight
months pregnant
um wow yeah i was pregnant i was
having the due diligence all of it uh
from the company's perspective
um and i think just to kind of give a
little bit of background is is abn bev
has kind of been a strategic partner
throughout the years
was a strategic customer that we were
serving um so so there was kind of a
direction a pretty clear direction that
this is kind of one of the ways that it
could go
um and we understood at the time that
this was the right way to go you know
this was the way to reach
real scale and real impact right to make
sure that we really have a good product
fit because ibm bear was you know
exceptionally close to the bars to their
customer base
um and there was also a fantastic
cultural fit as far as
as far as kind of the companies and the
values that we believed in
so it just kind of made sense um it was
stressful that said i think that there
was great kind of communication and that
visibility and transparency to the
employees is super important
so it was it was communicated of you
know guys this is kind of the direction
and you know nothing's gone through yet
but this is this is what's happening and
i think it kind of gave a sense of
security to people as well
and i think like you mentioned in the
beginning it's more unique in the sense
that it was really a beer kind of
conservative company buying a technology
company
so there was no real overlap in terms of
like you know people kind of concerned
about their job we were really doing
something unique
um that kind of wouldn't be switched out
by other people so i think from that
perspective
super interesting time um i gave birth
to two babies one was the acquisition
and one was my baby life my first son
um i probably should have said it
i came back from uh maternity leave
um and i think that that was super
interesting because i had that like
perspective of
before and after in a very unique kind
of way of right
you know i had that like cut so i could
really see you know
over a six month period what it changed
um
and i think that that you know the
leadership really did a great job in
keeping the company kind of intact
um you know the same kind of leadership
the same people a lot more focus
um you know which which i think is very
positive um you know from
from the company's data from from the
startups perspective
um and really the scale the scale that
we needed to reach you know
the data and the consumers and and yeah
from that point of view
so it was really an amazing experience
and i think you know i'm very fortunate
to
have been able to have experienced that
what are your key takeaways from that
time from those months of you know
nerve-wracking due diligence
i'm assuming that i can only assume that
when you go through a process like this
when you have a potential buyer and in
the leadership team the
team that within weisberger you sort of
decide yes
we might this is something we might want
to pursue let's let's do our best
what what how what do you take away from
this time especially being eight months
pregnant of course we can't
uh forget that um i think actually
especially being eight months pregnant
you realize that the things that you
don't always have control over and a lot
of uncertainties
so the same as like you don't know what
it's like what it's going to be like
when you have your first child or you
don't know what it's going to be like if
things go through if they don't go
through
i think it's just kind of understanding
how to manage uh you know manage your
expectations and uncertainties and
and kind of say you know what these are
things that i'll do my best and i don't
have control over them
and uh you know try to try to kind of
find peace
peace and just not knowing and not
having that full control
right yeah that's a good lesson for us
in toronto i love it
so so so what's happened so what's
happening today what what what what
what is change what stay the same and
what's your current position there
so um basically i guess uh you know i
did go back
uh post acquisition and and after
somewhat about a year and a half or so i
kind of started feeling like i needed
uh needed a new challenge you know i
believe that once you reach
kind of a certain plateau you you need
to move on to to the next thing
that we always need to be growing and
learning and and i try to
to do that in my everyday life um so
basically what had happened was
i started looking completely outwards
and started looking at like different
industries
maybe i'll join a vc maybe i'll do all
sorts of things and
i really spend some good months doing
some kind of exploration with myself and
a lot of chats with
people um about their career paths right
and i also believe in opportunity
meaning like to be able to identify
this is an opportunity that's knocking
on your door like yes there's definitely
an element of time but
you need to be able to identify um and
at the time
um kind of following the acquisition ibm
started to to increase their activities
in israel
so a couple of things happened one uh
their vp of saber
of global cyber team actually moved to
israel to start a team
so we actually have a sovereign team
from the tech cabin israel why does a
beer
company need a cyber team
um actually first of all like any big
corporate
a you know a beer company is no
different from any other big kind of
corporation
um and especially if you're dealing with
certain um you know consumers and
and certain e-commerce arts and things
like that i mean you know
you definitely want to make sure uh the
machinery
poison in putting poison in in our in
our products you know
there are a number of different reasons
but in any case we've got an amazing
cyber team
that's so cool the previous cto of the
vice verse also
moved over to ibm bev to lead the entire
data and architecture of the company so
that's another very
proud uh moment for us um and then at
the time
um an israeli um who had been working
in the new york offices moved over to
israel to lead the tech innovation hub
which is is the hub that i've joined so
they've basically been running for a
couple of months
um already making amazing traction in
terms of bringing senior leadership from
the company over to israel and running
you know great projects and
sustainability and
and agriculture and and really really
cool things
um and basically yeah i had the
opportunity and he said hey you want to
come and join us and lead
the commercials the commercial side so
that's the marketing and the retail and
things like that
and and logistics and i just have to
mention i never saw a warehouse
or i've never driven in a truck so this
was like a very very interesting
challenge for me um and i'm like okay
i'm up for these challenges you know
you've got to keep learning you got to
keep
evolving so now i lead logistics
innovation
uh globally yeah in the tech hubs so you
know amy
just on this past 15 minutes what i'm
hearing logistics marketing
communication
a strategy m a leadership
and of course legal so what what i did
what excites you at the end
i mean it sounds like you're you're
you're a woman of all trades but
but you know when you get down to it and
you wake up
tomorrow morning what do you what do you
really really really want to do
okay so um i think i'm just excited in
the morning to wake up and and to learn
something new
um and and like i mentioned i truly
believe that if i'm if i'm waking up and
learning something and learning
something can be learning something new
in the field that i'm dealing with so it
could be learning something about tier 2
logistics distribution which is one of
the
areas that we look for for technology
and it could be something
uh like an ai course that i just
finished doing because i felt like i
needed to strengthen
my understanding that's one of the
stronger technologies we're looking at
as well so
i think as long as i'm learning i'm open
to to what to what is to come
you know i think that that's something
that we have to really to to be kind of
you know one of the things that assaf
mentioned on on your uh talk yesterday
with him and i really liked is like
you need to come in with a strong
opinion but kind of be flexible and open
and i rarely relate to that i think you
need to come in with things that you're
passionate about and that you want to do
but i think you also have to kind of
have that openness to learn
because we don't know everything i i
completely agree and that's definitely
something that
that i think with me wherever i go you
know i'm always curious about this
if you would go back to yourself you
know back in
you know back in university or even back
in johannesburg
what would you tell yourself back then
because it sounds to me that you've had
this wealth of experience that you never
accounted for and you never thought you
would you were going to do when you're
doing your internship at the legal firm
correct me if i'm wrong i i don't think
you you intended later to go and do
marketing and business development
and and and helped do lead the due
diligence of an of an m
a so what would you tell your younger
self in hindsight
either to make the process easier or to
perhaps you know
make it a little bit better for you
um i actually have a very strong uh
strong
belief in what i would have told myself
which is
let go of the life you have planned
to accept and embrace the life that is
actually waiting for you and i think
i had a lot of resistance towards
letting go of dreams that i had and
letting go of specific kind of things
that i'd always envisioned
and i think that that's something that
we hold on to a lot of things that we
should be doing
because that's what i studied because
that's what my parents expect me to do
that's right
and i think you know to be able to let
go of that and say you know what like i
said there's opportunities
for growth for learning for there's so
many things we didn't even know existed
and be open to that um and and don't
kind of resist that
and i think that that would have made
kind of a lot of the the processes that
i went through
a lot easier you know one of the things
that i'm i'm extremely
both passionate and curious about here
is i'm walking down you know the halls
of stanford and
and i see a lot of people that are that
are you know they're choosing their
major and they're
and you know they're deciding where
they're going to what they're going to
do
a lot of the times when i ask them why
are you choosing this path or another
path
there's no real good answer very rarely
i hear
because that's something that i'm truly
truly passionate about i think coming in
a little bit older i do have the
privilege of coming in knowing what i'm
truly passionate about
and what really drives me curiosity but
but i definitely think that you know
this piece of advice it's it's very
scary going through these
experiences and feeling like you're
you're in some
you're on some path and some expectation
of you and so i definitely
very much resonate with what you're
saying and also just to add to what you
said i think uh i recently heard a
podcast i think it was the author of eat
pray love
and she speaks about how um you know not
everybody actually has passions and i
think that that's also something that we
need to not be so hard on ourselves
and says follow your interests and
that's also something that sometimes you
can kind of
that interest can develop into a passion
and not not to be hard on the people
that kind of don't feel that burning
desire to do something specific right
what was it difficult coming back to
to to ebby in beven and
you know coming with a very young baby
you know
leaving the acquisition you know eight
months pregnant
what was that transition like for you
obviously you know it's very relevant to
you know a lot of the discussions that
are happening today but about women in
tech
and and i'm always very curious to hear
about the different perspectives of on
how
on how that process was for them so i
can say that i had a lot of kind of
i was very nervous uh generally going
into to kind of
you know starting a family and and one
of those reasons was because i
you know i'm very ambitious and and i
would like to have a career and i
thought you know how would that impact
and how would i be able to manage
and i think what i realized is that as
people we have capacities
to hold a lot of different things and a
lot of different passions and a lot of
kind of different streams the same as we
can work on different work streams you
know at work
so i think that was one of the things
that i realized that i'm actually able
to hold
you know passion and ambition for work
um you know a lot of
love and care and and and concern for my
home
um so i think from that perspective i
realized that it didn't lose i didn't
lose myself in that way
um i think it also is very much a
function of who you work with i'm very
fortunate to have
you know amazing supportive you know
leadership and colleagues who are very
supportive i think
in corona you see that now you know
we're all wearing so many different hats
um that that you know you're in
conference calls with like senior
leadership and you know you have a
two-year-old jumping on your left and
and that's a part of that and i embrace
that
and i think that as you know becoming a
parent i learned to be a lot more
focused a lot more productive
i learned how to prioritize better and
and you know what's important what's not
important how do i you know manage my
work
workflow because i need to you know
specifically finish by a certain time or
something like that
and a lot of flexibility you know we all
work in a very flexible world you put
your kid to bed you get back online
i love it so that's pretty easy
right definitely definitely amy 20
minutes go by very very fast
but before we leave i have to ask you
for three words that you would use to
describe yourself
okay so i think i've alluded to them so
the first one i'm going to go with is
multifaceted
okay you know like i mentioned kind of i
wear a lot of different hats
so i'm a mom employee you know beer
tech all these other kind of elements in
aspect
and the second one i'll go for is
passion i'm passionate i
put love into everything that i do i'm
very much to do what you love love what
you do
i love it hard for me to work from a
different place
um and the last one is human um and and
to me what that means is
kind of i crave that very very deep you
know authentic human connection i think
i'm very much like you i like to connect
with people i understand their
motivations
um you know what makes them tick um and
and
can be connecting and networking and
work related or not work related
um so i think yeah it was really hard to
choose but
i love it amy today thank you very very
much
stay safe stay healthy and keep helping
us
and make a fantastic beer and
distributing fantastic beer
and very very thankful for that as well
and especially thankful for your time i
know you're very busy and
it's very generous of you so thank you